thank god you're wearing the CPAP man I
saw the tweet I tried he says he can't
no I don't I don't want to hear this I
did I did contact the old sleep study I
made them send me my results so I can
get a new machine that might be more
updated and I want to get sinus surgery
and go in front of the test cuz I can't
breathe so I want to have another test
but I the mask has been on my mind a lot
and I have my results I want to get a
new machine an updated machine can I
tell you something and don't get mad you
look bad you're not getting sleep right
you're my bags our bags right am i right
no you're right the bags are their bags
up and they're gonna give you wrinkles
too doesn't give a [ __ ] he wants us to
be the same Robert I don't care I'm not
no wrinkles I'm 51 I don't have any
wrinkles but he's gonna give you always
been there you looked good with the mask
when i retweeted I was like oh he's
getting sleep finally you were happy for
me I was able to do it for ten minutes I
do want to try it you inspire me but I'm
just not able to sleep with it it's it I
can't wake up but I'm burping because
it's pushing errands yeah yeah yeah but
you have to get past that hurdle right
you gotta get past it yeah you do you
get past it man I sleep so good now I'll
sleep for two hours with the Basques I'm
good for a whole day so you're on the
road constantly a world traveler to
figure out how to get you're sleeping
because otherwise you'll be dead yes
exactly
no made me want to do it and I do want
to get it I put a couple of masks that
might be a little bit better but they
didn't quite fit once I get the right
man wait I think I thought you know I
thought you were mouth breather no I do
I have so many masks I probably have 30
massive fans of selling but this one
covered your mouth because I had sleep
apnea when I was huge and it went away
see it's not a thing about being fat for
know what yeah wait wait like I lose
weight all of a sudden that the pressure
on that's right yeah but that wasn't it
for me for some reason same here it's
not a weight issue it's the only issue a
tongue issue and I have the brain one so
that will suck what's the brain one it's
called central sleep apnea where okay
your brain just forgets to send a signal
and my brain will just go dad we got
something to do but we can't remember
watch
breathing what it is so you need a big
machine on your face to remind your
brain I just loved it like Jim always
has so much going on in his brain like
he's got all these projects happening
and your brain is so functional that
when you sleep your brain is just like
Nam I'm out - I'm not anything how many
seconds when he did when they tested you
did they tell you how many seconds or
even they probably did I don't remember
mines bad is it hi oh yeah it's like 60
I think oh my god you know it's like 60
times I stopped oh I had moderate sleep
apnea did you have like severe my severe
yeah I had moderate but still bad enough
yeah so you travel with your mask yeah
do you have to do carry on with it
yeah so do you ever put it on in a plane
no I tried night this is the funniest
[ __ ] to Philippines I'm flying to the
Philippines I plug it in knock out the
whole first class literally I see well
that's like you'd have to go to the
first-class lounge you have to go to
first class and say hey everybody you
have two options here I'm gonna fall
asleep
so either I'm gonna snore something
severe and disrupt everybody or I need
all the electricity yeah yeah you make
the choice I I made the choice for them
I need distilled water in my eye you
can't bring on a plane no you can't but
I wouldn't do it I was gonna do it dry
I've done that yeah with note with
pretty you literally get dry in your
throat no yeah yeah but it's worth it
was a 14-hour flight so I was like I got
it yeah I gotta have some what did you
do I knocked out four it knocked out
everything but did you want what were
you able to use on the plane no it
knocked out everything I knocked
everybody how they had I have an ASV
machine CPAP I can't use ASV is the one
I needed but CPAP baya is better cuz
there's a million of them and they had
like little teeny portable battery
operated ones you man do ya do you not
just hear how you you did that you would
you could hear it no I thought you
starting to have
I've always a bad sign does it work if
you do it like with like a French
Bulldog you're supposed to put like a
stick in their mouth all right I have a
nicely prop their mouth open is that
what a mouth guard
it pushes my jaw for the mouth corner no
it helps me a little bit you use it
almost every night oh you were doing
anything it doesn't help with the
central so there's this new thing they
got no I swear to god it's a tongue you
stick your tongue in this like tube yeah
and he squeezed down and it holds your
tongue forward so you think like just
leave it like this yeah I've seen that
so uncomfortable it looks stupid but
it's the best thing for you but doesn't
it dry your tongue out like crazy it's
probably awful yeah but it's pulling
your tongue cuz what Jim and I have it's
our our tongue classes in the back of
our throat it just yeah it just settles
back down Rogan uses one that he told me
about years ago yes oh yeah he's the one
that got me onto the mouth really which
was the one he uses I think if he still
uses it is it goes in the back of your
teeth and it holds your tongue down he
goes you got to get used to it because
it feels like you're gagging yeah but
it's almost like if you had like a
finger holding your tongue on to the
floor of your mouth and that is what he
said it sleeps much better with oh I got
to get that Joe did you get excited when
you hear about like new apnea technology
I do I'm really bad man
I'm Beth the minute I like I can't even
take a nap like people like people I'm
just gonna close my eyes for a few
seconds I can't
joking me man are you married no mm-hmm
see I had to do this next to my wife in
the bed like looking like dog [ __ ]
Vader don't wear the mask you made me
want to do it though and I was using it
everyday for like an hour watching TV
making myself maybe I'll go back to if
I'm just too stuffy practices I can't be
stuffy you guys got the sinus and then
yeah I need surgeries to both I got is
there a surgery you can do for apnea or
no well they see not to do it especially
when you're uh
like our age when you talk for a living
to they can they can scar the back to
your throat yeah and it hardens so it
doesn't collapse but I don't to [ __ ] up
my throat yeah that's what they said to
me too
that's with it right mm-hmm like don't
cut it yeah can you imagine that like
you can say it's like something out of
The Twilight Zone
you can sleep fine now but you can't
talk anymore and that's how you make
your entire life yeah exactly
great like that's a joy and the recovery
is like a month I'm like dude did you
add that up for me how much a per week
is for me yeah good yeah we can't just
choke have you ever do you take time off
my [ __ ] you oh I'm sorry Sam but my
machine is that 19 pounds what's that
mean you travel with a 90 pound Michelle
no no it's like 1900 psi or whatever oh
I don't know what mine was it took me
almost a month to get the results from
the doctors yeah five years ago huh
where they sent them but they they have
all that calculate what it takes to make
you sleep peacefully and all that [ __ ]
there yeah you're out do you have to go
for retest yeah I just went in it's so
crazy the guy that uh that's taking care
of me he I did this joke on my own like
my special on Comedy Central was a light
towel and I talked about sleep apnea and
he uses that because he does these
seminars and he uses it for his opening
he goes man my seminars are so boring he
goes you're the that's the highlight of
the seminar play all right and he was
doing it for like ten years
he was like for ten years he's been
doing he's never met me or anything and
we're at a restaurant eating and his
wife keeps looking at me and he walks up
she was like dude I use you for my
seminars all the time can you come in I
want to take care of you I'm taking care
of everything so he takes care of
everything so you can you fall asleep
when they wanted to me the great genius
who maybe doesn't exist yet whoever
figures out how to get your sleep study
without wire connecting you to ever yeah
because I piss a lot so they could do it
like Wireless little things the one I
had was a battery pack it's like this
big I hooked around your neck I took it
home for the night that's the genius
this is a different one that's a
different one the one I had I know which
one you mean had to hook me up to a
machine yeah I talked to the hospital
and say like look I went to bed
sometimes I have to piss a lot is it
okay if I wet the hospital bed I would
like to if I bet it would mean I think
up this is crazy
oh yeah like this is how you know Jim is
in a situation right now as an adult
he's come in while we like on this show
and he's prideful he said that he's
woken up and he's wet the bed as an
adult what and he literally likes it
no he does because it means he's had a
good sleep also as an aside he leaves
the piss sheets for the housekeeper to
take the freaky part that's just
additional information but he just looks
at the housekeeper goes good night sleep
what his sleep is so bad because I get
that like I have like if if my pillow
hasn't been kicked off the bed I go oh
man I slept like a rock last night for
you if you wake up with a nice piss
stain on the sheet it's like oh yeah it
doesn't happen often it's happened like
once every five years by the way come
but it's true is there's piss all over
the place there that's great it means
because I'm my body wakes me up to piss
yeah time yeah but when it didn't it
meant that I probably just slept right
through it yeah we probably this idea
yeah you slept through it for sure or
you find out you're sleepwalking you're
just standing up on the bed just if you
were always into ghosts pissing on you
anyway so yeah but that doesn't help me
sleep Michael in North Dakota has
something about this I'm gonna majo know
if you've ever heard of this what's
going on Michael big Martin boy hey I've
had this same problem that you're having
Jim and I've had the surgery and I I
wake up in the middle of night and I'd
ripped the mask off I can't breathe I'm
gasping for air okay
and I've got the Nspire implant implant
put in last December and there's a leaf
that goes into your lung and a leaf that
goes up to the back of your tongue
then you turn it on with a remote at
night well and it just starts moving
your tongue toward while you're sleeping
you don't even notice it
I've heard of that yeah I know I've
heard that and again I don't know if
it'll work for my central a penis thank
you sir but yeah I've heard of those
things they can implant I can make you
breathe I don't know if I want that like
what I can't take the mask off I have to
my wife would be hitting the [ __ ]
remote on and off the whole night just
to [ __ ] with me hmm yeah you should get
you should marry somebody else
this is what Jim was thinking it just
didn't taste fresh yes it reminds me of
that moment so yeah we have to wrap up
soon we're leaving I'm happy that you're
here for a few minute and then ice mark
I sparked the conversation up with sleep
bad I don't mind everybody everybody's
got to trust me when I tell you there
are more than one person listening to
the show that might have some weight
issues and apnea issues yeah hey there's
ladies with it too you're right I want
women to think you know you have it too
yeah I sleep loud [ __ ] your ear choking
you need the man bodies killing your
body yes rejecting you're not supposed
to my own face hates my guts you just
have naturally occurring apnea like oh I
wasn't supposed to survive like I'm not
supposed to be alive you know you know
the way if you see a game of Thrones yes
the way Peter Dinklage's father looked
at him that's how my face looks at me
that's how you look at you yes how I see
may throw you in the river but yeah
you've inspired me man and I I keep
trying like you try it but it made me
move a little bit and I can now I kind
of stopped again but now that I've seen
you I will all I have you you've shamed
me into it a good way good good Sam's
not gonna [ __ ] help you all do I know
he won't bleeding you think he doesn't
wanna change the name so bad real quick
real quick change out he wants top
billing so it'll be a quick a week
attributes and then off to follow we
bring ot back
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app
[Music]